good evening everybody and
welcome to all and echoing hannah's
apologies for a slightly late
start it is great to see such a full
house
for this debate and the motion of our
debate
tonight anti-zionism
is anti-semitism anti-zionism
is anti-semitism there is so
much meaning packed into those words
meaning which stretches down the
centuries and meaning which reaches into
the lives
of millions of people today anti-zionism
anti-semitism these terms
are very fraught anti-zionism
often defined as opposition to the
existence
of a state of a jewish state
in the territory defined as the historic
land of israel or palestine i'll repeat
that
often defined as opposition to the
existence of a jewish
state in the territory defined as the
historic land of
israel or palestine anti-semitism most
often defined as hostility prejudice or
discrimination
against jews now surveys suggest that
israel is one of the most disliked
nations in the world along with iran and
north korea but how much of this
is driven by policies of the israeli
state
and how much is a cover for age old
hatred
of the jews these are the questions we
will examine this evening
so let's go to our first speaker for the
motion melanie phillips who is
a journalist broadcaster and author she
has a weekly column
in the times newspaper she writes for
the jerusalem post and jewish chronicle
melanie the floor is yours
ladies and gentlemen i never visited
israel
at all until the year 2000 and i never
wanted to go there
it didn't sound the kind of place which
had anything to offer me
so when in the year 2000 i objected as a
matter of
sheer rationality and justice that while
israelis were being blown to bits in
buses and cafes during what was called
the second intifada
they were being called nazis for dealing
with the perpetrators
i was astounded to be immediately
attacked
as a jew i was accused immediately of
dual loyalty
of being too jewish and of waving the
shroud of the holocaust to sanitize the
crimes of israel
well i think you can see the same
pattern in today's labour party crisis
over anti-semitism in which anti-semitic
motifs about
jewish global conspiracies are conflated
with attacks on israel
at one meeting jeremy corbyn noted of
two
zionist opponents in the audience that
despite quote
having lived in this country for a very
long time they don't understand
english irony using the smear that as
british jews
they didn't actually belong in britain
the palestine solidarity
campaign is riddled with anti-semitic
comments such as that the paris
bataclan massacre was a false flag
operation to increase support for israel
or that kristallnacht was instigated by
communist
and freemason jews to promote war
against germany
today a german neo-nazi group has linked
to the bds movement noting with approval
its efforts to
isolate the zionist aggressive state in
defense of the rights of palestinian
people
the language of bds and the far right is
interchangeable
those who say anti-zionism is not
anti-semitism would have us believe that
all this is simply a coincidence
i say it is not and that anti-zionism is
weaponizing anti-semitism and this is
why
let's define first of all what we're
talking about
what is zionism nothing more or less
than the self-determination of the
jewish people
in their ancient homeland of israel what
is anti-semitism
a delusional hatred and fear of jews
judaism or the jewish people
but anti-semitism is not like other
prejudices it has unique characteristics
applied to no other
group people or cause such as an
obsessional and unhinged
narrative based entirely on lies
accusing jews of crimes in which they
are not only innocent but the victims
holding them to standards expected of no
one else depicting them as global
conspiracy of unique malice and power
amazing anti-zionism has exactly the
same characteristics
don't get me wrong criticism of israel's
policies
robust criticism is entirely legitimate
but anti-zionism is different
anti-zionism demonizes dehumanizes and
delegitimizes israel in order to bring
about its destruction
you may hear some of this slander this
evening the lie for example that israel
is an apartheid state
when israeli arabs have equal civil and
religious rights
the lie of ethnic cleansing when the
arab population in the disputed
territories is more than quadrupled
since israel's rebirth
in 1948 the lie that the israelis are
willful
child killers when they in fact go to
unique lengths to avoid killing
civilians
in their always defensive wars and when
the ratio of civilians to fighters that
the israelis kill
is at least three or four times better
than any other country
including britain the lie of israel's
human rights violations
when it's the only country in the middle
east where arab muslims and christians
women and gays
can live in freedom and safety
fundamentally anti-zionism is based on
the big lie that the jews seized and
occupied in other people's land
but history and law show that's
completely untrue
the jews are the only extant indigenous
people of the land israel was their
kingdom more than three thousand years
ago
driven out when it was occupied they
maintained a continuous presence in the
land
under the waves of colonialism a syrian
roman abbasid mamluk ottoman the british
they fought off arab colonialists to
re-establish their state in 1948
and are still fighting off arab
colonialism
the palestine mandate of 1922 which
parceled out the former ottoman empire
enshrined their right to settle
throughout that land
a right that endures unaltered in
international law
the law also entitles israel to hold on
to land
seized from its attackers while that
land remains the launch pad for attacks
demonstrably true
the jews are therefore fully entitled to
live in both israel
and the disputed territories even though
they have
always agreed to share it with those
arabs who lay a claim to it
but the palestinians have refused to
share it and have responded
to repeated offers of a state of their
own with terrorism and war
israel is the only place where jewish
peoplehood makes sense
but anti-zionism singles out the jewish
people alone as having no right to their
homeland
of course many groups aspire to our home
now but israel is not an inspiration
israel is a country no other actual
country is singled out for destruction
and the mass murder that would
inescapably follow no one tells the
kurds for example their aspiration to
our homeland is illegitimate and racist
people say zionism is racism because of
the big lie the jews stole the land
anti-zionism thus writes the jews
uniquely out of their own history
it is an anti-jewish calumny now people
say
anti-zionism can't be anti-semitism
because some jews are anti-zionist very
true
but in fact they have always been jewish
anti-semites karl marx to name but one
who wrote quote the emancipation of the
jews is the emancipation of mankind
from judaism yes a small fringe of
ultra-orthodox jews campaigns against
the state of israel
but they nevertheless pray every day
that the jews should return to live in
zion free of foreign rule
their beef is they think the return in
israel is premature
and should happen under different
conditions so their problem is a matter
of timing
what they do not believe is the core
doctrine of anti-semitism
that the jews have no right to the land
of israel
now there's a vital distinction to be
made between anti-semites and
anti-semitism
many many decent people believe these
lies about israel
out of ignorance or ideology that does
not make them necessarily anti-semites
but the discourse they endorse is still
anti-semitism's current mutation
moreover by supporting palestinianism
they are supporting not just
anti-zionism but anti-semitism too
the palestinians real agenda not two
states but exterminating israel and
replacing it by palestine
as they repeatedly have told us over the
years is based on an
anti-jewish animus the evidence of this
is all around
mahmoud abbas doctorate in holocaust
denial
his hero worship of the 1930s grand
mufti in jerusalem
al-husseini who made a pact with hitler
to exterminate
every jew in the middle east the
grotesque nazi-style imagery of
palestinian propaganda such as sermons
claiming the jews are the fabricators of
history
who dance and live on the body parts of
others there is no global corruption
their rabbis did not allow
palestinian claims that the jews are
behind 911
and that they control the world's media
finance and u.s foreign policy
this unhinged murderous anti-semitism
drives the palestinian
cause does anyone therefore seriously
suggest
that people in this country who support
this cause and who say that the jews
were behind 911 and controlled the
world's
media finance and u.s foreign policy
that this really is just a coincidence
and if our opponents this evening really
do believe anti-zionism is free from
anti-semitism
will they denounce this palestinian
agenda of genocidal
nazi-style jew hatred this is not an
academic debate
when i grew up in london anti-semitism
was confined to a few nutters on the
fringes
who were treated as pariahs and now it's
been legitimized
not surprisingly anti-semitic attacks
are running at record levels and what's
so
distressing is to hear our right as jews
to our own peoplehood
being singled out as illegitimate and to
hear the
unhinged and obsessional lies and
distortions about israel become the
default position
of fashionable conversation and then
into on top of that then to be told
that the claim that people like myself
make
that these are anti-semitic conspiracy
theories
is itself a conspiracy got up by the
israel
embassy and it's supposed to be we jews
who have no sense of
english irony anti-semitism in
conclusion ladies and gentlemen
always attacks jews as a collective
first it attacked us
as a religion then it attacked us as a
race of people
now it attacks us as a people as the
collective jew in israel
with exactly the same characteristics as
jew hatred through the centuries
the aim to be free of jews now takes the
form of the aim to be free of the jewish
state
anti-zionists treat israel as a jew
among nations
to be uniquely vilified slandered and
exterminated
that ladies and gentlemen is why
anti-zionism
is the new anti-semitism
thank you melanie so now our first
speaker
against the motion ilan pape
is an israeli historian an anti-zionist
activist
a professor at the university of exeter
he has challenged traditional versions
of israeli history
elaine pappa you have the floor for 10
minutes
[Applause]
the equation that is being put in front
of you tonight
is both outrageous and ridiculous
if only because it makes every
palestinian in the world
almost everyone who lives in the arab
and muslim world anyone who regards
themselves
as liberal or on the left it turns all
these people
into anti-semites whereas quite a few
people who regard themselves as zionists
like the christian zionists
are actually anti-semites themselves but
it is important to challenge it because
it was used with some effect
to stifle the debate on palestine in the
west this allegation is used in order
to prevent the promotion for positions
of power
of politicians known for the long-term
support for palestine
by defaming these politicians as
anti-semitic
official israel and his supporters
worldwide hope to bring
down them down as in the case of jeremy
corbyn or delegitimize them as in the
case of ilhan omar
in the american congress so this is a
good opportunity in an appropriate venue
to say loud and clear
that if you are against zionism or if
you define yourself as i do
and anti-zionist you are not anti-semite
or in my case a self-hating jew which my
doctors told me
is an incurable disease and i would have
to live with for the rest of my life
i will make five points one long one and
four or five short ones anti-semitism is
an old ugly attitude that demonizes jews
because of who they are
and led in the past to horrendous
policies of discrimination
and genocide it still prevails today and
despite the passing of years it's
basically not changed much its origins
are deeply rooted in the christian faith
and were adopted by more in more recent
years by right-wing supremacists
and some extreme islamic groups
anti-zionism on the other hand is a new
phenomenon as a zionism
and dates back to the 1820s when as you
know zionism began
as a christian project before it was a
jewish project and then it was part of
an
internal debate within evangelical
christianity
anti-zionism then was a moral position
against romantic nationalism
and christian fundamentalism that today
we call christian zionism
christian zionism is an evangelical
belief that the return of the jews to
palestine
would precipitate the second coming of
the messiah the resurrection of the dead
and the conversion of the jews to
christianity or their barbecuing
in hell now these barbecuing christians
who are very important are anti-semites
who want to get rid of all the jews they
don't like and get in return the only
jew they want
jesus christ it's a double bill
they are today the most important base
of president trump and his ilk
and there are the most important
zionists in the u.s
providing immunity for israeli policies
on the ground
when jewish activists and intellectuals
adopted zionism in response to
anti-semitism in the late 19th century
their antagonists were mainly other jews
they were either orthodox you who saw a
premature return to palestine as
tempering with the will of god
and regarded as a heresy the
substitution of rich monotheistic
religion with the ideologically poor
modern idea of romantic nationalism
so there were definitely not
anti-semites other jews believe that
supporting universal ideologies such as
liberalism or socialism
would be the answer and if they had to
move
geographically from anti-semitic
environment environments they preferred
to go somewhere else
mainly to the u.s but not only to the
u.s
they were also not anti-semites when
zionism became a settler colonial
movement on the ground with the building
of jewish colonies in late ottoman
palestine
and during the british mandate the
palestinian national movement
perceived zionism as existential threat
to the indigenous people of palestine
a fear returned to be valid as
transpired
with the 198 1948 ethnic cleansing
of the people of palestine during the
nakba opposing the jewish settlers
and their plans for the palestinians
homeland was not anti-semitic
but anti-colonialist very much as the
algerians objected to the colonization
of algeria
a small group of the jewish settlers
became anti-zionists themselves when
they consented to live
within arab palestine as guests but not
as colonizer
as was advocated to them by mahatma
gandhi in the 1930s
and because of that position there is
not
he was never honored with a street named
after him in israel
not even a small pathway or a staircase
after the creation of the state of
israel in 1948
anti-zionism as an anti-colonialist
ideology continued to inform the
palestinian national
movement's vision and strategy as is
manifested in the plo
national charter that calls for the
establishment of a democratic secular
state in palestine
that would respect all three religions
in israel itself the communist party
supported
almost exclusively by the palestinian
minority inside israel not because of
the communist ideology
but because it was the only anti-zionist
party israel allowed to exist
they regarded zionism as an ideology of
discrimination
in apartheid most scholars today look
again israel
then and today agree that this is a
valid point which again has nothing to
do with anti-semitism
two in our century our anti-zionism is a
moral position
against the israeli structural violence
directed at the palestinians which is
attributed by
anti-zionists such as myself to an
ideology that is not only
endangering the very existence of the
palestinians but is also very bad for
the jews who live
outside or inside israel this ideology
generates anti-semitism
opposing it might bring it down in our
century anti-zionism is a scholarly
position
a moral stance and a vision for the
future as a scholarly position it frames
zionism
as settler colonialism similar to
european settlers movement
who went to the americas south africa
and australia
encountering indigenous people and
removing them in order to create new
homelands for themselves
it's a moral stance that rejects an
ideology that imposes an apartheid
system inside israel
a military occupation in the west bank
and siege on the gaza ghetto
it's a vision for the future of a
democratic state for all by restoring
justice to the land
by respecting united nation resolution
194
calling for the unconditional return of
the palestinian refugees expelled in
1948
and since then akbar this may be a
utopian view
but it's not an anti-zionist one
anti-semitic one
three for those who claim that
anti-zionism is a refusal to recognize
the right of israel to exist we should
say
that states do not exist by right they
are they are founded by historical
processes
and they become a feta complete the
debate is about the nature of the state
and the regime
we are all entitled to wish for and work
for a better
more just and egalitarian state for
everyone who lives in israel in
palestine
and for those who were expelled from
there four in 1975
a vast majority of the united nations
member states defied zion defined
zionism
as a form of racism and racial
discrimination
it was passed with the same majority
that passed the 1947 resolution
recognizing israel
the difference was that in 1947 the
colonized world was not
represented in the united nation in 1975
it was when he was still trying to find
its way in the postcolonial world
the third world's discourse equated
zionism with continued colonialism
alas neoliberalism corruption and
postcolonial politically
and postcolonial political system
corruption in the post-colonial
political system and aggressive american
imperialism
have cast it to the sideways of history
this impulse and energy
but at its height and within it
anti-zionism was part of the wish of the
colonized people
to build a better and more just world
again nothing to do with anti-zionist
with anti-semitism when the 1975
resolution was revoked in 1991
the debate on zionism entered a new face
its present phase
after the horrific events in 911 and the
so-called war and terror
the israeli hasbro invented the threat
of a new anti-semitism
this was the only way to repel the moral
outrage people around the world fell
towards the policies of incremental
genocide in the gaza strip
and the brutal oppression of the west
bank if you voice criticism
against this policy you were depicted as
a new anti-semite
and israeli academia was recruited to
provide scholarly
scaffolding for such an accusation the
western elites bought or were
intimidated into buying this false
allegation
but the civil society and in particular
the younger generation
reject with disgust this attempt to
silence them
they know enough to call the bluff and
understand the full meaning
of solidarity with the palestinians they
demonstrate in the streets in their
campuses
enjoy the palestinians on the ground at
the personal cost
to show how outrageous it is to call the
pure struggle for justice
anti-semitic if you are an anti-zionist
today
you are not only standing firmly on a
sound moral base
in condemning this ideology that
generates all these crimes
you are also expressing your disgust at
the hypocrisy of your government
mainstream media
and academia we will not be silenced by
false accusation of anti-semitism
and neither should the british labor
party be intimidated by cynical media
without a moral backbone or sinister
legislation efforts utilizing a
justified struggle against terror
in order to provide immunity to
palestine's colonizers and oppressors
finally the labour party is responsible
in many ways for the debate we have
today
we all know that the so-called
revelation of institutional racism
institutional anti-semitism in the
labour party
began not on the day that corbyn was
elected as a leader but after two
attempts to depose him
and failed then suddenly the campaign
emerged
i know the force of this campaign of
intimidation i faced it myself it is
ugly
unfair and destabilizing but the proud
party with the historical role of
defeating fascism in this country the
1930s
should not so easily succumb to false
allegations
of anti-semitism finally
we should retake let us five
five sentences let us retake the
conversation
and prioritize it let us discuss how to
stop
the destruction of palestine and the
palestinian which the
trump's deal of the century wants to do
let us fight violent fanaticism wherever
we encounter it
approved racism of all kind without
building a hierarchy of victims
and removes silly and outrageous
equations
like the one titling the event tonight
thank you
thank you elaine so on to our
second speaker for the motion inet
wealth
and energy has been a member of the
israeli knesset
for first labor and then the
independence party between 2010
and 2013 and she has written extensively
on zionism anat the floor is yours for
10 minutes thank you
so we seem to all agree that
anti-semitism
is bad of course educated
knowledgeable people are unlikely to be
seduced by it
because we know where it leads nazism
auschwitz and the gas chambers
but anti-zionism does not appear to be
in the same category
it appears to be good we heard here that
it is about
supporting palestinians about fighting
for human rights
educated knowledgeable well-meaning
people
might support it but the anti-semitism
we all acknowledge as bad
when it started looked nothing
like where it led in fact
when you compare the beginnings of
anti-semitism
with anti-zionism the similarities
are striking anti-semitism began
by creating a new collective designation
for the same people which rendered them
different
in secular 19th century europe it was no
longer
jews but semites and it never was
intended to meet anything
but jews in the soviet union who claimed
to not
notice different religions and peoples
jews were designated
as zionists and today in the west
in the uk zionists
zios the designation
is then described as having essential
immutable
loathsome qualities in christian europe
we were christ killers to the nazis
we were an impure race to the soviets we
were capitalists and imperialists
and today the state of israel is the
ultimate violator of human rights it is
described as
born in sin it is guilty by its very
nature of the crimes of racism apartheid
ethnic cleansing nazism genocide
the designation of the group and
ascribing of essential evil qualities
is always given the aura of rationality
and respectability
by relying on the greatest source of
authority of a given era
religion in pre-modern times science in
the modern era
human rights in our own
the aura of the greatest authority is
necessary
because the collective transformation of
the jews
into a loathsome other requires that one
be
willing to twist reality if not
outright ignore it it is only by
appealing to the authority of religious
doctrine
that all jews living in the 12th century
could be collectively designated as the
killers of
christ over a thousand years earlier
it is only by appealing to the authority
of a perverted science
that the very jews who contributed to
european society
could suddenly be considered as
endangering its racial purity
and it is only by appealing to perverted
version of human rights
that zionism in israel could be
designated as its
greatest violators it is
only by perverting the idea of human
rights that those who
were actually ethnically cleansed from
every part of the arab world could be
accused of ethnic cleansing
it is only through the sort of
perversion that the people who
repeatedly said yes to partitioning the
land into a jewish state in a
palestinian state
could be described as those who stand in
the way of a two-state solution
and it is only through this perversion
that in an age when the idea of the
nation is still
tied for almost all states to the idea
of a common history
language ethnicity and remnants of
religion
israel is singled out as uniquely
deviant
but why go to all that effort to single
out
a group and distort reality
because we humans have a primal need
for scapegoats and for whatever reason
my people have been the designated
scapegoats for so many
and for so long for medieval
christianity we stood between a brutish
and nasty world
and salvation for germany for europe
we stood between them and glory
for stalling we stood in the way of
communist utopia
and today why bother fighting
colonialism in its aftermath
easier to designate zionists as
colonialists and blame them
why do the hard work of fighting racism
and its many manifestations
across all societies easier to designate
zionism as racism and apartheid and
blame it
why acknowledge the tremendous
difficulties of living up to the ideals
of human rights
designate zionism in israel as its
greatest violators and blame them
but the problem with human scapegoats is
that
unlike ancient animal ones humans might
resist their sacrifice a bit more
and we can't have that happen can we
so action must be taken to reduce their
resistance
how strip them of their defenses
push them to the margins step by step
take away that which protects them but
it must be done gradually
anti-semitism did not start by stripping
jews over their citizenship confiscating
their assets and pushing them into
ghettos
it started by slowly pushing jews
out of the positions they were able to
attain after
several decades of european emancipation
it operated by making it more and more
difficult
for jews to feel comfortable in european
society
anti-semitism also lured jews into
dropping their defenses
preventing them from organizing against
the coming danger
telling them that if they were the good
kind of jew
for example in germany those who fought
for germany in world war one
they would be spared they were not
note how anti-zionism operates now
its main targets are the two places
where jews have
organized most effectively for their
defense
the state of israel and the pro-israel
lobby in the u.s
the legitimacy of both is relentlessly
and uniquely
questioned jews now designated as
zionists
are increasingly pushed out of certain
spaces
jewish students in the u.s are slowly
pulling out of universities
known for their virulent anti-zionism
liberal activist jews are finding they
are increasingly unwelcome in
progressive circles
jews here in britain are finding they
can no longer be
in the labour party their traditional
political home
wondering if they might one day have to
leave the country
altogether anti-zionism
also lures jews to give up their
defenses
we heard it here why don't we all live
together
in a single state yes we know that
nowhere in the arab world have jews ever
been treated as equals
and were violently ethnically cleansed
when their dared raise their heads
yes we know that binational states
certainly in this region but not only
descend into bloody mayhem but we assure
you
this one will work just forgo your
insistence on having your own state
where you control your defense
anti-zionists also insist on their
respectability
they will try to convince you that the
fact that the targets of this new form
of virulent hatred bear a striking
resemblance to those who were targets in
previous times
is sheer coincidence they will insist
that the fact that the
charges against this group appear like
variations on the ancient themes of
anti-semitism
is sheer coincidence they might even
convince you they are fighting
anti-semitism
but the old easy to identify kind which
we already know is bad
and this is where it all comes together
in the past waves of jew hatred and
anti-semitism
did not arise from something that those
who were hated
actually did it arose from a crisis in
the society
of those doing the hating
and in an age of crisis especially a
crisis of identity
when we no longer sure who we are what
we stand for
we desperately need certainties and
there are few greater
certainties in this world than that the
jews
did it and so the zionists are
designated as a collective group
which happens to coincide with the group
previously known as semites and jews
they are then ascribed the most
loathsome qualities of our time by
appealing to the great authority of our
era
and then they are slowly subject to a
process
designed to strip them of the means of
resisting their ultimate role
escape vote for the crisis of the era
and when that process would be complete
the scapegoat could
finally be sacrificed in the vain hope
that in doing so a better world with a
marriage
it never does and this is why the topic
of this debate is not just another topic
it raises the very specter that we might
be a society on the precipice
which is why we are here today in the
hope that
some of you will see the deep insidious
undercurrents
so that this time we will not have to
wait to see where anti-zionism leads
and only then look back in hindsight and
say
ah yes that rising wave of anti-zionism
was indeed the new form of anti-semitism
ana thank you and to our final speaker
who is our second speaker against the
motion
media hassan media is a journalist a
broadcaster
a prominent critic of israel he's a host
on
al jazeera english and he's a columnist
on the u.s
online magazine the intercept maybe the
floor is yours for 10.
ladies and gentlemen we have been
witnessing tonight a deeply
cynical proposition uh deliver a farago
of straw men
distortions deflections false
accusations
and of course straight up pro-israel
propaganda
then again hearing melanie phillips come
here and champion the rights of gays in
israel in order to defend zionism was
well worth the entry ticket
in and of itself so let's be clear
about what this motion is tonight
because it's the motion you all have to
vote on
in good conscience the motion says quote
anti-zionism is anti-semitism it doesn't
say some anti-zionists are anti-semites
which is true
it doesn't say anti-zionism can
sometimes turn into anti-semitism
which is true it doesn't say that
anti-semites often use
anti-zionism as cover as an excuse for
their bigotry and racism
which is true i wouldn't oppose any of
that
but that's not what the motion says the
motion says
ridiculously sweepingly offensively
a historically that anti-zionism
is anti-semitism that merely being
opposed to zionism
a political ideology remember is
inherently by definition ipso facto
anti-semitic which is absurd think about
the implications of
voting for that tonight you'd be saying
every anti-zionist
every anti-zionist is a bigot
a racist and an anti-semite by
definition
even the many jewish and israeli
anti-zionists
so elam jewish historian born and raised
in israel served in the israeli military
he's an anti-semite that's what they
want you to believe that's what they
want you to vote for tonight
so is the former speaker of israel's own
parliament the knesset avraham berg
melody would say he's a self-hating jew
so is my intercept colleague naomi klein
the acclaimed
author and climate change activist so is
noam chomsky he's an anti-semite as well
they want you to vote for them and say
that the thousands of haredi ultra
orthodox anti-zionist jews
who oppose zionism for religious
theological reasons they're anti-semites
too
that's what they want that is what they
are asking you to vote for
tonight it's absurd and it's a
historical
don't take my word for it listen to the
35 top
israeli jewish scholars and academics
historians of the holocaust
who came together just a few months ago
and published an open letter in which
they wrote and i quote
many victims of the holocaust opposed
zionism
on the other hand many anti-semites
supported zionism
it is nonsensical and inappropriate to
identify anti-zionism with anti-semitism
end quote are they anti-semites too
really all 35 of them by the way in
terms of the history they refer to in
their letter
it is an undeniable indisputable fact
that many many european anti-semites as
ilan alluded
did support zionism at the outset they
did embrace the founder of zionism
theodore herzl because for their own
selfish racist reasons
they shared his goal of treating jews as
a foreign
separate nation and getting them out of
europe take british foreign secretary
arthur balfour author of the 1917
balfour declaration
in favor of zionism balfour dismissed
jews as quote
an alien and hostile people he sponsored
legislation to keep jewish refugees out
of the uk
the only jewish member of the cabinet at
that time said edwin samuel montague
opposed the balfour declaration and
called zionism a mischievous political
creed
yet apparently according to the
proposition tonight montague's the
anti-semite and balfour isn't
that's the madness that you're going to
vote for tonight
this motion is not just a historical not
just absurd not just offensive
it's a distraction it's a dangerous
distraction from the very real and
murderous anti-semitism that is on the
rise
and that comes not from the left not
from anti-zionist not from the bds
movement as melanie would have you
believe
but from a resurgent far right in
germany according to official figures in
2017
nine out of ten anti-semitic hate crimes
were carried out by far-right or
neo-nazi groups
i live in the u.s two synagogue attacks
in the space of six months
twelve innocent jewish worshipers
murdered in cold blood
by far right white nationalists and yet
the proposition tonight like the
netanyahu government
like the trump administration want you
to ludicrously believe
that the threat to jews right now the
real rise in the new anti-semitism
comes from the anti-zionists from the
bds movement from the palestinians
and not from the murderous far right
when the irony is that netanyahu prime
minister of the world's only jewish
state
has been cozying up to some of the worst
anti-semites on the right who also
happen to be
proud zionists let's be clear about that
many of the most prominent
influential right-wing anti-semites
today donald trump
victor orban steve bannon they're not
anti-zionists
they're hard right hardcore zionists and
powers of netanyahu
let's also just deal with some of the
canards we've heard tonight from the
proposition
adapt mentioned that it's anti-semitic
to suggest israel is born in sin
every black american i know
says to me and says to everyone else
that the united states was born in sin
slavery was a sin at the start of the
united states no one accuses them of
being
anti-white racist or anti-american
racist it's just a statement of
historical fact
they say the proposition that when you
oppose zionism you're denying jews and
no one else a right to
self-determination which is just flat
false
not every nation or ethnic group wants a
state gets a state has
a state asked to kurds ask the catalans
ask the scots
there are more than 5 000 ethnic groups
in the world today but only 193 member
states at the united nations
take the druze an arab ethnic minority
group 100 000 or so live in israel
do they have a right self-determination
if they create a drew state inside of
israel is anat okay with that if anat
says no you can't have a drew state
is she racist towards the druze
national self-determination doesn't
always correspond with statehood
melanie says it's not racist for the
kurds to aspire to statehood she's right
it's not
but the flip side of that is true as
well the british government the american
government most of the eu governments do
not support kurdish statehood
does that mean the british government
all of us are racist towards the kurds
people have legitimate debates about
where state line should be drawn which
states should be created how those
states exist
it's not racism or bigotry to have that
legitimate day
it can be but it's not by definition the
issue is not whether
jews deserve a homeland or have a
historic connection to the land of
palestine of course they do
the issue is whether those historic and
religious claims justify
creating and expanding a jewish majority
state in which one ethnic group is
privileged over another
while another group is permanently
disenfranchised dispossessed
and subjected to endless military
occupation that's what we're here to
oppose tonight nothing more
nothing less and has the proposition
even stopped to ask
what it means to say to that oppressed
group the palestinian people
to say to them that you're either a
zionist you either subscribe to the
ideology of your oppressor
or you're a racist what kind of choice
is that
melanie says tonight that denying jewish
nationhood is racist it's anti-semitic
and yet she has no issue erasing the
palestinian people from the face of the
planet
she said in her speech that only the
jews have a unique right
to nation and state to and in that part
of the world not the palestinians
what is that is that not bigotry is that
not racism is that not wiping the people
off the face of the planet
but this is what you'll be voting for
tonight if you vote for the proposition
this is what the israeli
pro-israeli argument has always been
to silence the palestinians to silence
their opposition to occupation
to silence their resistance as
palestinian citizens living inside of
israel
to a nationalistic ideology which treats
them like second-class citizens
which denies the many of the rights and
privileges of the majority
and one thing i want to make clear to
you tonight you don't have to be
an anti-zionist to vote with me and
elaine tonight
you don't even have to be a critic of
israel you can be the biggest supporter
of israel in the world and vote with the
opposition
all you have to be is someone who
recognizes that it is an egregious smear
a naked slur to claim to label those of
us
jews and non-jews alike who oppose a
political ideology
in good faith because we think it's
unjust iniquitous oppressive
to label us as anti-semites for holding
that political view
all you have to be is someone who
recognizes that the claim that we
hate or are opposed to jews simply
because we don't agree with the idea of
a state
that privileges one group over another
makes us racists
so let me repeat to be clear tonight's
debate is not about
israel per se it's not about whether you
support or oppose israel or the
occupation
it's about whether you believe the
proposition have made the case
that those of us who oppose israel in
its current form
who oppose the political ideology
underpinning it
that we're racists that's the bar that
has to be crossed tonight
it's that simple and i'll tell you this
for free
those of us who value our free speech
who don't want to see
anti-semitism cynically weaponized by
supporters of israel
who oppose that ideology of zionism in
good faith with good reason
we will not go quietly into the night we
will not be silenced
we will not be bullied we will not be
cowed we will not be smeared
so ladies and gentlemen stand with us
against this unjust
inaccurate irresponsible dishonest
ludicrous simplistic
sweeping motion which conflates judaism
a great and ancient religion with
zionism a very modern political ideology
and in doing so risks emptying
anti-semitism
of all meaning ladies and gentlemen
stand with us tonight
oppose this awful motion
thank you
thanks all for listening and thank you
to all four of our panelists for
absolutely brilliant opening speeches
now
it is time to announce the result of the
vote taken
as you were coming in and before you'd
heard a word of those speeches
this is the picture of how you felt when
you walked into the room
tonight for the motion
15 against the motion
59 undecided
26 so i'll repeat that the motion
obviously
anti-zionism is anti-semitism for that
motion
15 against 59 percent
undecided 26
now we're going to move on and have um
some discussion with the panelists i'm
going to
sit back a fraction so that they can
actually see each other
and engage a bit and i want to come back
to um
to melanie because we haven't heard from
her for a while just put we'll just do a
couple of questions up here and then
we're going to throw it open to all of
you on the floor
um so melanie why don't you deal with
this
charge from the other side um that
you're attempting to silence a moral
position
well um mahdi says that
we produced straw men i'm i i find it a
surreal experience having listened to
him
because he misrepresented uh everything
that i had said
he went on and on about how you have to
vote with him because
we iei have said that anyone on that
side is an anti-semite and racist
i'm sure you ladies and gentlemen heard
me say very explicitly that i was
certainly
not saying that i draw an extremely
important distinction
between anti-semitism and anti-semites i
said explicitly
that by no means everybody who supports
anti-zionism is an anti-semite by no
means everybody who supports
anti-semitism is an anti-semite people
support
stuff that they believe to be true
because they are ignorant they're
ill-informed they're ideological for a
variety of reasons
i can't see into people's souls i'm
sure that methi hassan and ilan pepe are
both
deeply honorable men i would not presume
to say what is in their minds or what
their motivation is
i do not presume to say that people who
support anti-zionism
and who would wish to deprive the jewish
people of their
rights to live in their own homeland are
anti-semites
i am saying something different i am
saying
that the discourse is at fundamentally
anti-jew why not because
israel the jews alone are entitled to a
state
in the land of israel again mehti says i
said that
i certainly did not say that you ladies
and gentlemen will have heard me say
explicitly and in terms that the
israelis have
always always agreed to
share the land with the palestinians
right so they have been offered they
have been offered a state of their own
in 1936
in 1947 and on repeated occasions
in the 2000s and their response has been
to the offer of a state of their own
living in peace and harmony alongside
the jews of israel
their response has been terrorism and
war
i would dearly love to see that happen a
state
of the palestinian arabs living side by
side
i don't think it's going to happen but
that's another story
but it is simply a wicked lie to sit
here
and grotesquely reverse
what i have said melanie okay we
we we've heard that now ilan coming to
you
you talked about ethnic cleansing of the
palestinians we heard anet say
jews have not been equal in the arab
world
anywhere so who's doing the ethnic
cleansing
and do you accept that point oh i accept
the point that
after the creation of state of israel
the jews of iraq
were expelled from iraq
under an agreement between the israeli
government and the nuri said government
because zionism didn't want the jews of
iraq to stay in iraq
and neither did the nationalist iraqi
government want them there
but this has nothing to do with what we
are talking about
we are talking about the fact that half
of palestine's
population within nine months
was ethnically cleansed by the jewish
and israeli forces
500 out of 1 000 villages were
demolished
wiped out upon the earth 11 palestinian
towns were depopulated
by force this was not immigration
this was not a call as in the case of
jews in north africa
by a new jewish state to jews and come
and be with us
it's better for you to be a jew a
moroccan jew in israel than a moroccan
jew in morocco
this is a different story here we are
talking about
a crime against humanity that was
committed within nine months in 1948
that there is no other definition for
this otherwise why
would half of palestine's population
become refugees
if they were not expelled by force by a
settler colonial movement
so you've made these points already deal
with the point about the inequality of
jews in the arab world
i can deal with first of all the jews
were treated in the arab world much
better than the word that they were in
the christian world
far better far better and
and it and especially especially in
countries such as ir
can we just here to speak please
especially in countries such as
iraq in egypt in morocco until the rise
of zionism
jews were holding positions of power
jews led
secular rich and religious life
and all this fabric that was holding on
for
centuries was broken down first
by the zionist ideology that all jews in
the arab world
that they do not belong to the arab
world and by
a reaction by fanatic arab nationalism
saying
okay so you have to decide whether you
are zionists
or you are jews okay thanks this history
right we're moving on
um can you deal with media's point
please that um
that you and melanie is suggesting that
every anti-zionist
is a bigger than a racist that this is a
naked slur
that is such a simple rhetorical trick
make things sound so extreme so
outrageous and then people say
oh that's not what we meant that's not
where we thought
the motion is very clear and again this
is not an academic debate
the topic here tonight is not just
anything any policy
this is about people's lives
here and today in effect
in the uk in the west
anti-zionism has become the respectable
shiny way of being anti-semitic
because we already have
and the reason that people want to
separate the two
is because they need the cover of
respectability
to continue to gain adherence if you
knew it was anti-zionism you would
reject it
because anti-semitism you would reject
it because you would know where it leads
but as long as it's presented to you as
something rational
and remember anti-semitism in the
beginning
also appeared rational it was also
supported by elites
it thrived on universities nobody
thought
it would lead where it led because
that's how it gained adherence
by people thinking that it was different
that it was new
and this is what we're seeing we're
seeing a concerted
effort to maintain the respectability of
that position
so that the process of dropping our
defenses can continue
thanks for that um and and maybe one for
you can you just deal
with melanie's point the distinction
between anti-semite
and anti-semitism the suggestion that
there's a discourse that was
fundamentally entered you know i can't
deal with it you'd have to ask me with
it because it makes no sense to me the
idea
that you can say the idea i'm sorry
when we talk about academics in real
life let's get away from universals
with respect to elan the idea that you
say let's all vote tonight the
anti-zionism is anti-semitism and then i
say i'm an anti-zionist and you said but
you're not an anti-semite that makes no
sense
capitalism is something you say you're a
capitalist i mean this is this is
pedantry to try and pretend
that you can go after the ideology but
not the people who identify with that
ideology
it's absurd to say that by the way anat
mentioned that it's a rhetorical trick
uh to do that which is a nice line but
then she literally in the next sentence
went on and said
unless my ears are deceiving me
anti-zionism has become a respectable
shiny way of being an anti-semite so i'm
an anti-semite who's using anti-feminism
in a respectable shiny way why not just
come out and say it i don't know why
you're hiding it
call me an anti-semite are you oh
my god am i an anti-semite because i say
i'm an anti-semite i know you're not
melanie are all the palestinians
anti-semites because they're all
anti-zionists
just say it be brave be brave
say it right we're going to open this to
the floor now
unless you want to answer in it
absolutely people who
think that the jews alone have no
right to be masters of their fate who
want us yet again
to be powerless to go back to
how we used to be there is only
one name for that i'm not making it
personal but yes
i am here today precisely to fight
the veneer of respectability that
anti-zionism has
because i don't want to wait to see
where it leads
people waited too long thinking that
anti-semitism
in europe was scientific was respectable
we know where that led i don't plan to
wait
we've heard that right it is time
to hear from um all of you now um
so there are ushers with mike's i should
say do please raise your hands
go for it and then and then in a moment
we'll take the second vote
so uh let's have number one and
number two and let's just go in that
order one first thank you
thank you and my question is for melanie
i think you're great as well so thank
you for everything and
well we know where your loyalties lie as
you ask your question
um long story short i'm 19 um i go to
kings and i study religion philosophy
and ethics
and i studied judaism
i'm a muslim but i chose to study
judaism and i read arthur crystal's
the 13th tribe of israel and he says
um ashkenazi jews they were um european
race that converted two days can we have
the questions yeah
so my question is um do you think that
there are
some jews living in israel who are
originally of european descent not like
you say
they were historically the most
historical people that's ever lived in
the land in israel or do you think
that's just another lie as well
hold that thought we'll have question
number two please um a question
for mehdi and melanie the
newly elected mp for peterborough lisa
forbes
has been branded in some quarters an
anti-semite
because she partly because she signed a
letter
um objecting to certain examples in the
ihra
definition of anti-semitism what
do you think about this thanks for that
okay let's deal with those questions
first then
um so melanie do you if you can deal
briefly with the first question
the history um so i didn't actually
understand the question
i'm so sorry um i didn't quite
understand what you were talking about
were you saying that some jews are not
jews is that your point
that they're not converting europeans
it's
you were saying that jews they're the
most like
they are the longest people who have
lived there for the longest time
historically
but some jews have converted from
european christians
to jews so actually they weren't the
longest people that lived there because
they used to live in europe
okay so maybe palestinians were the
longest people that have lived there
because
they were living in europe okay can we
just have a
we need to get through quality quick
answer
um uh the
the the simple answer to your question
is that the jewish people are the only
people for whom the land of israel was
ever their national kingdom
several hundred years before islam was
invented and the arabs invaded
and that is the point i was making they
are the only people for whom israel
is their national kingdom the fact that
some jews for the fact that many jews
haven't lived there is
self-evidently true but that is not the
point
the jews are entitled to the land of
israel because that is their ancient
historic homeland
with from which they were dispossessed
by waves of colonial
uh invaders and which they have got back
from colonialism and which some people
think
is actually that they should not be able
to do that that's the point i was making
okay thanks for that
um we're not going to um spend more time
on the deep history right now coming to
the peterborough question
made he did with that we are we were
asked for um
views on the um on the letter yeah
i don't know about the letter i do know
that she i mean i don't live here so i
don't follow labour politics as much as
i used to but i do know that lisa forbes
uh liked a facebook post which referred
to theresa may's
uh zionist slave agenda or some such
formula
in my view that's clearly anti-semitic
she has her excuses
she says that she didn't read the text
she was trying to support a video that
was in solidarity with new zealand
victims
you know each to their own whether they
believe or not i don't know the lisa
ford's i don't know anything about her
all i can say is
that statement saying theresa may has a
zionist uh slave agenda it's clearly
anti-semitic
it's where quote-unquote anti-zionism
does go into anti-semitism i think i
opened my speech
by considering i've never denied
you've answered that question um number
four please can we stand up sorry
now thank you can we have can we have
some questions to our other two speakers
now
speakers uh for the motion i'd like to
ask you uh to comment on nagba and how
do you think palestinians
should be dealing with um the
consequences of naga thank you
thank you and um down at number one
i'm going to take a couple all together
to get through some more we're running
out of time
hi um well to paraphrase brett stevens
and and peter beinert anti-semitism
is anti-zionism is not anti-semitism
but it might as well be practically
speaking
but we're dealing with a lot of
semantics here and my question
is uh i'm having a little identity
crisis
i'm jewish i'm a zionist i'm deeply
troubled by 1948. i wouldn't call it
ethnic cleansing mr pape
it was a strategic choice we need to do
okay it was a strategy because it is a
time of work my
question is why are we
this is almost masturbatory you should
pardon the expression
what is the solution we're all thinking
kind
people what is the solution who's your
question to
all of them okay i'm going to ask that
one so that one can be for ilan
um what's the solution and we had i was
up
i think up someone up here yeah we were
going for
yeah number three please hi just wanna
this is a question
for uh the opposition why
is uh israel singled out as a human
rights violator
in the united nations by the labor party
by many other
entities as compared to
so many egregious violators of human
rights
including in the middle east why is it
consistently
singled out is that
not a form of anti-semitism thank you
for thank you for asking question that's
great
so um ayna i want to hear from you first
on on the question of nagwa which is
um who would like to just define nakba
the best for us
you're the historian
give us the historical definition in the
sentence yeah
is an operation of ethnic cleansing
which was a systematic expulsion of the
palestinians
in order to de-arabize palestine and
create
on its ruins a jewish state
in 1948 but okay thank you no no no it's
important to say
the nagba continues because only
50 of the people were expelled
and only 80 percent of the land was
taken
the nakba continues every day in gaza
in nablus in the galilee in the nakab
and we should have a discussion about
the destruction of palestine
and not about the nonsense that we're
hearing here tonight obviously this is
the palestinian term
for what happened in 1948 it means
catastrophe anat
i i'm not sure if you accept that
definition we just heard from milan but
anyway deal with that that's not a
definition
okay but uh
the story is very simple the arabs of
the land the palestinians could have had
again and again and again a state of
their own
they could have had it in half of the
land in 80 percent of the land
but every time when they were told you
can be
masters of your fate in part of the land
but in another part the jews will be
masters of their faith
no longer inferior to you no longer
submitting to you their choice again
and again and again to the present has
been
to fight for all they have again said
if we have to live next to sovereign
jews
better to fight until they are not there
at all
and i will say this again when you fight
us
we three years after a genocide and you
wage
a genocidal war telling us that we have
no right to defend yourself
then we will fight you back we
will defend ourselves
sometimes have nothing um maybe why
is israel singled out yeah i don't
accept the premise of the question
obviously it's interesting you should
say that israel's singled out
there's a little r going out well if
you're watching this on youtube
go back on youtube and see that the
first intelligent square debate i did
was not about israel i came here a few
months ago to talk about
the kingdom of saudi arabia and its
human rights abuses so
before i even turned up for israel i
came to condemn saudi arabia
and on and this i get it i get it there
are lots of u.n resolutions
uh condemning so i get that but if you
look at actual practical sanctions
there are no sanctions on israel from
western countries for human rights
abuses there are against syria
there are against russia there are
against iran there are against north
korea so no i don't think israel is
being singled out i'd actually like to
see sanctions put on israel so it's
treated like other human rights abusers
consistency single standards
right right i we we have
i i want to give everyone on the panel
an opportunity to answer the question
that we had from down here which was
what is the solution so a moment for
optimism but but literally only a moment
each melanie can you go first
two sentences please uh what is the
solution it depends
what the problem is if you define the
problem in the middle east
as a contest between two people with the
rights to the land
over the boundaries of that land then
you end up precisely where we are but in
my view that's not the situation at all
the real situation is different if you
want a solution to the real problem
you have to stop the 100
year attempt to exterminate israel as a
nation-state of the jewish people
and to exterminate the right of the jews
to live in israel as their own sovereign
country
that is what the situation is in the
middle east however you would like to
reframe it
that is what the problem is if you want
a solution you have to stop
people trying to commit a a genocidal
assault
upon the right of the jews to live in
their own country once again
you got the solution thank you elan what
is the solution if you could just give
me two sentences i'd be grateful
the only viable solution is to change a
reality
where with between the river jordan and
the mediterranean you have now
12 million people 6 million palestinians
without any human rights and civil
rights
and six million jews with all the
privileges in the world
only one state that ensures
equal rights for everyone regardless of
their nationality
religion race or gender
is the only solution and the return
of the refugees that have been expelled
yes because the region is known for
having so many of those states
the only response
is for the arab world to finally say
something very simple welcome home
to accept us as an indigenous people
who are in their land to accept us as
equal claimants to the land not
exclusive
not superior but people have an equal
right
to finally be masters of our fate
in the land of our own in part of the
land
next to arabs who will be masters of
their fate in
part of the land that's the only way to
live together
okay and and i'm always amused
ain't made a crack in her speech and now
again that we know what binational
states are like in the middle east
i'm always amused when israelis say this
because last time i checked 20 of the
israeli population is palestinian so
it's already a bi-national state
we just want to give the palestinian
part of that state equal right every
year
arab mps palestinian citizens of israel
in the knesset almost every year
put a bill forward to turn israel into
quote a state
for all its citizens and every year the
president of knesset last year who did
it
will not allow it to even reach the
floor for deliberation so tonight i ask
aina melanie do you support an israel
for all its citizens because i do we can
call it israel call it whatever you want
but just give it a state for all its
citizens state of all its no it's not
in fact they literally blocked a bill
the supreme
the supreme court blocked the bill to
make it a state of all its citizens you
know that
you're a former member of the court okay
you've both had your
you've both had your say on that um
right
now we're going to go for our um final
statements from our speakers on the
panel summing up speeches to be made
seated
and to last no longer than two minutes
in fact do you know what all four of you
if you could
just kind of keep them really tight if
you can get them down to less than two
minutes
i would be grateful we're going to go in
reverse order so maybe you first
ladies and gentlemen if you still
haven't voted i want you to think of two
groups of people when you are voting
uh for whom opposing this crude cynical
motion is so important so crucial so
personal
the first group of course are the
palestinians because if you vote for the
motion tonight
uh you're saying despite melanie and
anat's best attempts to try and
play this uh you know oh it's ideology
versus adherence you're saying we all
have to be zionists
otherwise we're racist we're bigots
we're anti-semites which look
wouldn't be the end of the world for me
fine i'll be a zionist if you want me to
be a zionist i mean i once almost voted
lib dem i'm okay with
labels but to ask the palestinians to
just
not just accept their dispossession
their ethnic cleansing their ongoing
occupation
but to also call themselves zionists or
else
is outrageous you can't ask palestinians
to be zionists
you just can't and by the way if they
say it's racist
to oppose zionism well it's racist to
ask palestinians
not to oppose their own occupiers and
look if you don't care about the
palestinians
still vote against emotion tonight
because there's another group of people
you'll be throwing under the bus
if you vote for this motion anti-zionist
jews people like elan like my colleague
naomi like noam chomsky likely haredi
and
in a single sweeping move you risk
throwing all these people under the bus
jews who oppose zionism in good faith we
haven't talked about that today not once
did the proposition acknowledge that we
might have good reasons for our views
that we're not all trying to hide behind
what was it and said the shiny
respectability of the new
anti-semitism don't tar all those people
who are fighting for human rights who
are fighting in good faith
as racists as self-hating jews as
anti-semites for the sake of a political
ideology
don't do it don't do it whatever your
views on israel-palestine
vote with the opposition tonight against
this ludicrous dishonest offensive
motion
a nat now your closing statement for the
motion
i doubt there's a lot of good faith here
and i have to say
if zionists such as myself can support
palestinian self-determination i see no
reason why the reverse should not be
also asked
but i want to take us
and use this opportunity to go back to
the fundamentals into the big picture
a reminder about what is actually going
on in the mechanism
remember step one is the zionists are
designated as a collective group
which happens to coincide with the group
previously known as semites and jews
step two they are then ascribed the most
loathsome qualities of our time
step three it is done by appealing to
the greatest authority of the era
step four and this is where we are now
they are slowly subject to a process
designed to strip them of their defenses
but we were told today and are asked to
believe that this time the jews are
sorry the zionists
are truly to blame germans and europeans
too
sincerely believe that jews the semites
were truly to blame but we now know that
anti-semitism arose from a deep
crisis in the society doing the blaming
after all these templates and ways of
thinking about my people have been
around for millennia
yet they become particularly useful in
times of crisis
and we are indeed again a species in
crisis
technology questions our very
intelligence in humanity
extreme weather undermines our
confidence in our control
inequality undermines our ideal progress
our leaders or lack thereof leave us
feeling bereft of a sense there's a
steady hand at the helm and at times of
crisis
we desperately crave certainty and there
are few greater
certainties in this world to grab on
than that the jews are to blame
as a society we can emerge from our
crisis
but only if we ask ourselves how can we
all do better rather than who is to
blame
and i believe we can all indeed do
better
thank you
we heard a lot about the zionist
ideology
and the idea that the land of palestine
is the land of israel
always when you hear it think about
someone coming to you the dead of night
in london
and tells you i used to live in your
house two thousand years ago
and because of that the house belongs to
me and the next day
they come with the police
and the next and the next day they come
with the police who says
they have a right you have to give them
half of their house
zionism was a settler colonialist
movement
that was running away from persecution
but
it wanted as much of palestine as
possible with as few
palestinians in it as possible this was
the aim of zionism in the late 19th
century
this is the aim of zionism today we
are all entitled to go through
the same process that happened in south
africa
we are entitled as jews and as
palestinians
to live in one democratic state where
everyone is equal and stop and reject
an ideology that claims that some people
are equal
and some people are not
i'm asking you for the sake even for
jewish communities around the world
because settler colonialism in israel
will become
worse as the century will continue
for the sake of the people who live here
and the sake of the people who live
there we are entitled to have the same
kind of democracy
that everybody everyone else has without
boris johnson
thank you
thank you elaine and melanie
well i'm truly sorry that mehdi can't
understand my distinction
it's very simple my point is simply this
that people of good faith sometimes
swallow
outright lies because they believe them
to be true
and we've heard this evening some of
those lies come from the other side
falsehoods about israel which are
believed to be true
for example suggests that israel is not
a state of all its citizens that the
arabs somehow don't have full
equal rights he calls them palestinians
perhaps mexi doesn't also understand
that 20 or so of israel's population are
israeli arabs israeli arabs have full
equal rights you can see them
in the israeli parliament you can see
them in the israeli courts
you can see them in the israeli
universities
what meshti says what when he says
that this that that he wants a state of
all its citizens
he wants a state of israel which is not
israel anymore which is not a jewish
state
so the britons can have britain the
french can have france
the americans can have america but the
jews cannot have
israel i would say that is outright
discrimination
ilan says it's their house whose house
there were dozens and dozens of
different nationalities in mandate
palestine the arabs came in in large
number
because the jews were returning and
rightly they thought that they would
bring prosperity
in conclusion let me return you to this
the the proposition under under
consideration
is anti-zionism uh anti-semitism
mehti says not everyone can have a state
that is absolutely correct but why this
is a form of anti-semitism is the unique
nature of the animus against zionism
jews are the only people living in their
own historic homeland
who are deemed to have no right to that
homeland
and whose claim to self-determination in
that
homeland which is theirs by right is
illegitimate and racist
that vile bigoted malicious
animus is unique against israel
and it is why anti-zionism is the unique
calumny against the jewish people
and it has exactly the same unique
characteristics
as anti-semitism
thank you all for your summing up
speeches and
um that concludes our debate so it is
time now
to announce the final vote uh count
and a reminder that our motion this
evening was anti-zionism
is anti-semitism a reminder also that we
began
the evening with 15 for the motion 59
against the motion and 26 undecided
after 90 minutes of debate we end as
follows 19 for the motion
76 against the motion
and 5 undecided so the motion
this evening has been defeated this
house does
not believe that anti-zionism
is anti-semitism
you